this episode is brought to you by ridge
wallet
hey wisecrack jared here hollywood's a
tricky business
audience's tastes constantly shift over
time a genre that's popular in one
moment can run out of fashion
a second later but there's one thing you
can always count on
people love to be scared that's why no
matter the decade
horror films have been a constant
fixture in cinema from the universal
monsters of the 30s
to the slashers of the 80s and 90s to
the so-called torture porn of the early
arts
horror today though isn't necessarily
categorized by masked killers or
monsters
instead it's become mostly synonymous
with one company
blumhouse since 2007 blumhouse has
revitalized the genre with hit
after hit like paranormal activity the
purge
get out us and many more their films
have pushed horror into
uncharted territory gaining both
commercial and critical success
hell many have even labeled this current
period the golden age of horror
on the surface blumhouse's films all
appear to be different
running the gamut from ghost stories to
slashers to socio-political commentaries
i would have voted for obama for a third
term if i could producer and ceo of
blumhouse jason blum even stated that
he's always been very conscious of not
repeating himself
he said wearing my entrepreneur's hat
i'm very conscious of not falling into a
pattern
the tenets of the company are the same
but the kinds of things that we're doing
are very very different than 10 years
ago but the secret sauce of blumhouse's
success might actually be rooted in
being cheapskates
according to blum the only real pattern
is an economic one
unlike other studios which pour tens or
hundreds of millions of dollars into a
single film
plum house tries to make sure each film
costs no more than
five million by being so budget
conscious blumhouse has
strangely enough stumbled into making
some of the most insightful commentaries
on a basic
part of american life the home so let's
find out how in this wisecrack edition
on how blumhouse
changed horror and spoilers ahead for
blumhouse traits like paranormal
activity insidious
sinister get out halloween and us but
before we continue i want to give a
shout out to this week's sponsor the
ridge wallet
the ridge wallet is a light sleek and
industrial wallet designed to last you a
lifetime
each wallet is made with rfid blocking
technology which protects you from
digital pickpockets
the durable metal also means each wallet
comes with a lifetime warranty
so this could be the last wallet you
ever buy it's perfect if you don't want
to carry around a bulky old
lumpy leather wallet in your pocket and
still want to maximize the amount of
cards you carry
it holds up to 12 cards and still has
room for cash
i got the titanium gunmetal wallet and
nothing beats how sleek it is
the ridge team is so confident that you
will like it that if you don't and send
it back within 45 days you will receive
a full refund
grab your own ridge wallet today by
going to ridge.com
wisecrack and use the promo code
wisecrack to get 10
off you will get free worldwide shipping
and returns
so click the link in the description to
get one today and now back to the show
since blumhouse needs to keep their
costs low most of their films are set in
a single location
and shot in one of the cheapest easiest
places a filmmaker can find
a house money aside most horror films
focused on the opposite
showing what happens when people leave
their home just look at some of the most
popular horror films before blumhouse
arrived on the scene
in the 1960s a young woman left home
seeking safety in a creepy motel with
great amenities in the 1970s
a group of teens went on a road trip
only to face off against
this beautiful family in the 1980s a
family leaves home to become caretakers
at a hotel
only to be haunted by clear building
code violations
in the 90s some teen vloggers ventured
into the woods in search of a witch
and things didn't go much better i'm so
sorry
and in the early aughts a bunch of horny
college students went overseas only to
end up
well you can probably guess the template
in all these films
is the same a group of attractive people
go on a road trip or
camping or overseas and typically die in
the most horrific fashion
possible the message if only everyone
could just stay home
then nothing bad would happen in these
films homes are often depicted as
safe havens a refuge from the horrors of
the outside world
in the midst of terror characters will
often remark how they wish they could be
home or talk about what they're going to
do when they get back to their real
lives
and i'm just very hungry i'm very tired
and i'm very scared and i just want to
go home there are exceptions to this
rule of course but
two notable ones are the genres of the
haunted house and the home invasion
a typical haunted house film focuses on
well of course
a house in these films a group of people
will either knowingly or
unknowingly move into a haunted
structure the houses in these films
don't represent safety and security they
are unknown spaces that we know from the
start will doom yet
another set of hopeless fools and in the
home invasion horror genre
an outside force most often a killer
threatens the domestic stability of a
family
stalking and then attacking them in
their home the family must then ward off
their intruders like
an unwanted vermin and re-establish the
home as a beacon of safety
these films often end with the killer
being literally expelled from the house
and the closing shot is frequently a
wide shot of the house
the sun coming up in the distance
showing the horror is over
and everything is safe once more thus
ultimately the point of these films is
to restore the sanctity of the home
however blumhouse subtly began to shift
how horror films depict homes
in the process redefining both the
haunted house the home invasion genre
and horror as a whole take their
breakout hit 2007's paranormal activity
unlike the typical haunted house film
which focuses on a creepy gothic and
foreboding home
paranormal activities house is well
completely ordinary
there's nothing spooky or creepy about
the way it's portrayed
in fact the early scenes of the film go
out of the way to do the opposite
painting the most idealistic portrait of
the home possible
in the opening scene micah films around
his house capturing a shot of his
girlfriend returning home
which reveals their lovely suburban
neighborhood in these early scenes the
camera lingers on furniture and decor
like we're in an episode of mtv's cribs
and the exact same thing happens in
paranormal activity too the sequel opens
with the family recording
everything in their house for the
posterity of their newborn yet again
it's a cribs episode come to life the
camera showing off the open kitchen
the white sofas another huge ass tv and
let's not forget
a jacuzzi both paranormal activity films
take the time to show just how pristine
these homes are they are the
quintessential beacons of a safe
upper middle class life but of course
not everything is as it seems
a demonic entity haunts both households
though the first signs of it are
presented as common household
disturbances
in the opening scene of paranormal
activity katie thinks she hears
something strange
could it be demonic nah micah dismisses
the sound as just
the ice maker ultimately the demonic
entity escalates its attack
making itself fully known by literally
destroying the house
in paranormal activity the entity cracks
micah and katie's photographs and in
paranormal activity too
the entities completely destroyed the
house furniture's damaged
my daughter ellie's room master bedroom
yeah so that's great even worse there's
no way to get rid of it
not even a renowned ghost psychic can
help micah and katie
he takes one step into the house and
then well
in fact i've got to get out of here this
thing is very aggravated the home simply
isn't safe anymore
i can't i can't be i can't just let's go
please let's go paranormal activities
depiction of the home
somewhat coincidentally reflects the
growing anxiety around housing
in the lead-up to the great recession in
2007 the housing bubble started to burst
as millions of american households with
subprime loans found themselves
unable to pay their mortgage that year
alone there were over 2.3
million foreclosures the homes people
thought were their safe havens suddenly
became their undoing
per film historian james stone the
paranormal activity films track the
gradual collapse of the economic dream
the business of the demon is to lay
waste to materialist splendor each movie
takes place in a sizable well-appointed
home
and then it all comes crashing down
stone goes on to cite paranormal
activity too specifically
in the film one of the protagonists ally
discovers her family's ancestors had
made a bargain to become wealthy
by forfeiting the soul of their
firstborn son what if christy's
grandmother made a deal with a demon so
she could get rich however because the
deal was never fulfilled
the demons stuck to the family until
another son was born
thus the demon attacks because their
family quite simply hasn't paid their
debt
as stone writes the demon is an agent of
the recession because he claims and
destroys domestic space
and like a vindictive creditor the
monster begins his campaign of terror
after a deal is reneged upon blumhouse's
later films
insidious and sinister go even further
showing that it isn't just a singular
home or
family that is tainted but potentially
every household
insidious opens much like paranormal
activity depicting a seemingly ideal
home
yet the opening credits show something's
wrong right from the outset
we see still photographs of a beautiful
house a family having just moved in
yet in many of the shots pictures and
chairs move on their own
sure enough it's not long before the
family realizes they're in a haunted
house
i'm scared of this house there's
something wrong with this place i'm not
imagining it i can feel it it's
it's like a sickness faced with the
prospect of being paranormally
terrorized the family does the only
sensible thing they move
however despite moving to a new home
nothing changes
they begin to experience the same
ghostly hauntings yet again
it turns out that the family's comatose
son is a beacon for the supernatural
world
inviting the ghosts into the physical
realm thus no matter where they go
no home will ever be safe their house
will always be haunted
the same is true in sinister after true
crime novelist ellison oswalt discovers
his new home may be haunted by a demonic
entity he
yet again does the seemingly sensible
thing getting the hell out
yet as it turns out the entity haunting
the house bagool
is a demonic parasite that travels from
home to home mr oswalt
you just moved out of the last house in
line if this guy is still out there you
not only just sped up his timeline you
put yourself in it
it's only after a family moves that
bagool is able to possess the youngest
to kill the rest of the family
thus by moving ellison has inadvertently
placed himself
and his family in mortal danger both
insidious and sinister reject the notion
of a singular haunted house
in the traditional haunted house film as
long as you escape the house
you're safe however in both insidious
and sinister
the haunting follows the family fleeing
does nothing to solve the problem and in
fact may spell your doom
and it's not just the home but the
entire neighborhood that's no longer
safe
in the early 1980s and amid public
concerns around crime rates
a new form of living began to sprout up
across the country
the gated community in ed blakely and
mary gail snyder's fortress america
they detailed how americans were
increasingly choosing to move to these
supposedly safer communities
as they write americans of all classes
are fording up
attempting to secure the value of their
houses reduce or escape from the impact
of crime
and find neighbors who share their sense
of the good life in the purge the logic
of the gated community is made extreme
it's no longer one secured neighborhood
that keeps one safe from
outsiders but an individual's house
turned fortress
the sandins live in an ideal bright
suburban neighborhood where everyone
knows your name
it's the type of place where your
neighbors even bake you homemade cookies
the sandins have a deluxe security
system that is supposedly foolproof in
protecting them from the violence of the
outside world
as such the family believes they are
completely safe on purge night
i know bad things do happen tonight but
we can afford protection
so we'll be fine just like always no
worries okay however the sandins are so
focused on protecting themselves from
the outside world
they fail to realize the actual threat
is within their own community
it's not some other it's their neighbors
the same that gave them the delightful
treats the gated community of the purge
isn't a safe haven from the outside
world
it's the nexus from which violence
originates similarly get out
inverts the idea of these safe suburbs
by opening with a black man
a quote unquote outsider lost and scared
amongst the white middle class affluence
he got me out here in this creepy
confusing suburb
i'm serious though i feel like a sore
thumb out here
and sure enough his paranoia proves
right when he's quickly abducted in the
middle of all the perfectly cut grass
matching driveways and brightly lit
homes get out
does away with the very pretense of
safety in the suburbs instead the
suburban home is something to escape
to get out from when chris arrives at
his girlfriend's family home he
immediately notices something is wrong
it may seem like the typical suburban
ideal but underneath something
is amiss chris sees that the only black
people in the house are servants and
that they're acting
off later when there's a party at the
house he realizes that nearly everyone
there is white and staring at
[Applause]
it's like they haven't met a him person
that doesn't work for him of course it
turns out chris's girlfriend is part of
a weird brain transplanting cult and
that chris needs to kill each member of
the household to finally get out
in the end chris's friend rod surmises
the entire film in one offhand joke
i mean i told you not to go in the house
get out and the purge mark a shift in
how blumhouse films present the home
whereas early blumhouse films focused on
how seemingly idealistic homes and
neighborhoods are no longer safe
corrupted by unseen monsters these later
films present the home as symbiotic with
the monster
it's not that the armitage family has
corrupted an otherwise
nice suburb their evil is one in the
same in jordan peel's follow-up
us the wilsons and upwardly mobile black
family take a trip to their summer home
in an upper class beachside community
and yet again something doesn't feel
right but this time it isn't that
everyone else is out to get them
it's themselves they have to worry about
i can't be here i
it's too much it feels like
there's this um black cloud just
it's not too soon thereafter that the
family is attacked by their
doppelgangers resentful of their other
half's posh lifestyle
when the girl ate her food was given to
her
the message behind us boils down to what
does the dream of upward mobility of
suburban bliss
actually mean for everyone else who gets
to live in a house and conversely
who doesn't the literal real estate
occupied by the wilson family and others
means a cast of people who are relegated
to living below ground outside of that
dream the basic question of the film
posits
are there casualties in our quest for
the american dream the idea that holmes
can twist us beyond recognition
like adelaide forgetting she actually
came from the underground
is a recurrent theme in later blumhouse
films in get out if chris stays with the
armitages in their home
he will forever live in the sunken place
and then blumhouse is the invisible man
cecilia confides that she had to escape
her home because she didn't feel like
herself there
under her abusive husband's thumb she
was becoming a different version of
herself
he controlled how i looked and
what i wore and what i eat similarly in
blumhouse's halloween sequel
lori's daughter comments that she had to
get away from her mother and their house
lest she end up just like her i've spent
my entire life
trying to get over the paranoia and
neuroses that she has projected on me
later when laurie kills michael myers
she does so not by expunging the
boogeyman from the home
but by trapping him inside the home now
becomes a literal prison
just this year blumhouse released their
latest film you should have left
which not so coincidentally is about a
family trapped in a house which refuses
to let them leave
somehow blumhouse has yet again tapped
into the zeitgeist
in a time when people are stuck
self-isolating in their homes
this new film reflects these same fears
from the company's inception blumhouse
has presciently reflected the current
climate
often spookily predicting what's to come
blessed be our new founding fathers
and america a nation reborn from the
economic crisis of the early aughts to
today's quarantine blues how has
blumhouse been so consistently on point
is just a result of their cheapo
business model or if they made some
faustian deal with the devil themselves
it has been said that if a human makes a
bargain with a demon for wealth
power or any other benefit they must
forfeit their firstborn male
regardless the result is the same
blumhouse has captured the american home
like no
other twisting the place which we spend
the most time into our undoing
so wisecrack what do you think has
blumhouse made you afraid of your house
or do you foolishly still sleep soundly
at night
let us know in the comments below huge
thanks to our patrons for all your
support
purge that subscribe button of all its
demons and as always thanks for watching
guys
[Music]
[Applause]
peace
[Music]